all right today's topic i'm very excited
for the end of this week
for what for the end of this week why
because we've done like about like three
four videos on ukraine
and
folks have gotten really upset by them
which i've really enjoyed
uh why have you enjoyed the fact that
people have been upset because i've
enjoyed covering ukraine i've enjoyed
covering ukraine this like extremely
difficult
complicated um geopolitical issue and
doing absolutely zero research on it
it's been pretty much the highlight of
my new year so far
just being uninformed and talking about
this felt fantastic because we're not
really so much talking about the
situation
yeah whatever's happening i don't know i
don't really know i don't even fact
check anything i just look at pictures
repost them you know i mean i'm serious
i've been sending hearts and [ __ ] don't
give a [ __ ] i just want you guys to know
this is what happens when we cover
topics that we're not informed on
we just come out with the dumbest
funniest takes we possibly can and enjoy
ourselves
and i want you to know that this channel
it's a safe space
it's a safe space for stupid takes okay
this is an opportunity for you guys to
get more ignorant but i want you guys to
know that you are going to the bottom
with us okay it's a race to the bottom
it's been so much fun i don't even know
there's feminism in ukraine but i want
to take a shot i didn't give a [ __ ]
someone said we should bomb bomb ukraine
i said man listen
you're stupid i don't know what's
happening over there and as my good
friend andrew schultz would say when it
comes to this channel
we operate on a simple mantra all
feelings no facts
what you just said made no sense what
you mean because you talk about fake
news and then you talk about facts
all felix no fact
stupid did you not hear what i said all
feelings no facts
i felt like there was feminists in
ukraine no facts
okay you understand what i'm saying i
see the video of some racism ukraine no
facts but i felt offended
yeah yeah done yeah you got shades block
out the sun but they can't block my
feelings out
don't understand i'm here baby
i'm here with my business i'm gonna
enjoy myself you're crazy i'm not crazy
you're crazy i mean i've been purposely
enjoying this whole time
so all the people were getting mad at us
when we didn't cover palestine i bet you
grew up glad now no they're not i bet
you glad now
all right so the next time the next time
a world issue happens and i'm uninformed
and y'all [ __ ] i'm gonna point you
guys to this series of videos enjoy
myself you really think that people
what care
what that's true they want like there's
new people are going to come up to that
and going to be like
that like example like we were off uh we
were off for january right it's not the
first time that we you know take some
time off every time there's some
[ __ ] and why i'm not winning
i'm not going to stop publishing you
need to do this you need to do that
everybody in the dm no matter how many
times i'm going to say yo we do whatever
we want okay we do whatever we want and
you should talk about this why don't you
talk about that well you want to talk
about that
i agree but the difference is now we got
proof that's that's all that matters to
me i got evidence so all it is all this
was just to prove [ __ ] wrong
yeah yeah yeah my research is like yo
abba let me help them like [ __ ] shut up
google nothing
about you don't no no don't tell me
nothing you went you went you went you
went the same way about this situation
the way that our government went about
how to deal with gold yeah yeah they did
they went you know intuition brev i'm
literally starting a brand new network
called fake news
i'm here to enjoy myself this is a safe
space for stupidity
no it's not it is actually if it's a
safe space of stupidity it doesn't mean
that there's going to be always stupid
takes but no no but there's going to be
a lot there's going to be there's going
to be a lot and i mean i want you guys
to know i will obfuscate the truth i
will lie to crack a joke i don't give a
[ __ ] we're comedians hey yeah why did
you factor i can't be bothered i don't
care we do most comedy [ __ ] and
everything yeah we do yeah yeah yeah but
people heard there's trans people trying
to leave ukraine
hey man i'm talking about that i don't
even know if it's true i don't care
i i hope they snatched snatch that trans
woman's wig and threw it on the floor i
don't even know if they did it but i'm
gonna say they did that's hate speech
did that yeah it is yeah i'm gonna say
they hate it though yeah we're gonna
have a hard time getting that pass on
youtube though why would be you have
time i'm reporting fake news it's hate
speech it's not hate speech to report
fake news
i know i know the regulations
it's misinformation but it's not
so
i'm just enjoying myself i just want to
let you guys know that all the ukraine
videos that we've covered this week
they've been fantastic for me they've
been quite enjoyable now a lot of you
guys are still upset how dare you less
than that
yeah man this is what happens when
uninformed people talk about [ __ ] they
don't know [ __ ] about which is mostly
the news
that's facts that's right you know these
[ __ ] have been talking about
like all the ghost of kiev and they've
been like reporting a bunch of fake
stuff that they've even themselves
admitted is fake and you know what they
said afterwards they said well
it's still
encouraging a positive result i said you
[ __ ] yeah that's low-key that's
literally
misinformation that's that that's that
fouchy uh masks mask about bad for you
that's loki noble
that's the loki noble you know what i
realized
the internet is just a big old safe
space for misinformation and fake news
for dumb texas yep and i want you guys
to know that i will assert myself in
this domain
i don't give a [ __ ] i've got a lot of
dumb takes get ready for them you won't
even know the difference
and that's the scary part
when is admiral being dumb
when is he being right
when is the news being right so anyways
hopefully you guys been enjoying today's
video and the videos have been coming
out the last few days if you guys felt
more informed about ukraine as a result
of watching us uh no problem you guys
are stupid too and uh let's just all be
done together
we are living yeah a little submarine
yeah
i just felt like this song was just
appropriate and dumb enough